We're a family we fight with you
you won't win i've always found it best
not to look into the past okay
you got a plan or should i just
stay duck and cover my plan was to
drive us away okay your plan sucks
at some point we all have to choose between
what the world wants you to be and who you are
i made my choice
i'm done running
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
marvel black widow movie video there's a bunch
of announcements about what disney is going to be
doing disney and marvel with the actual release of
the movie people been asking about them putting it
on disney plus apparently there's some news about
that now so i'll explain what's going on and a lot
of it has to do with what warner brothers is doing
with their movies in 2021 and what's happening
right now in the world just in general with movie
theaters so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're obviously
in the middle of Wandavision i'm doing episode
videos for all that we're going to have falcon
and winter soldiers starting in march so there's
a lot of really really cool marvel stuff coming up
we're doing that disney plus memberships giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just leave all your predictions about the black
widow movie on the video so if you didn't see the
news in the past week there's a new report from
variety's insights team which is a very insidery
business report that they publish about the movie
and tv financials studio politics them releasing
movies and tv shows and in it they talk about how
disney is making some changes to their plans for
the black widow movie release date because of
what's been happening the last couple of months
and now at the beginning of 2021 in january you
may have seen that a lot of studios just delayed
all their big movies pretty much up through april
and last week kevin feige was doing a bunch of
interviews to hype up the wand division episodes
during those he talked about everything from
deadpool 3 to the fantastic four movie to their
new rebooted x-men movies they're doing in the mcu
but he also talked about what's happening with
the black widow movie because now everybody's
wondering if they're going to have to delay
it again you probably saw when all the movie
delays were happening people were making jokes
in their timelines like just wait for it disney's
going to announce they're going to delay that
black widow movie one more time it's already been
delayed almost as many times as the new mutants
movie last year when a lot of things got delayed
they figured that by this time and by march april
2021 things would be better theaters would be open
but so far that has not been the case the uk is
currently under a big lockdown the u.s has been
under a big lockdown there's still a lot of other
places around the world where theaters are not
open and won't be open for a while that's
why warner brothers came up with their
real grand plan to release all their 2021 movies
on hbo max last year like we need subscriptions
and it doesn't look like things are going to get
better so why don't we just put all of our movies
on hbo max and in some theaters on the same day
for all of 2021 but in terms of the black widow
movie right now just nothing beyond april has
been delayed again so there's still a chance
that they could hit that may release date but the
big problem that marvel has that a lot of other
studios don't have with their movies is that if
they delay black widow again they have to delay
every other marvel movie into like 2023 like
pretty much every future marvel movie one of
marvel's biggest strengths the connected nature
of its movies also becomes a big problem too like
we're at the beginning of marvel phase 4 right
now all the movies happen in a certain order for
a reason because each one tells a little of the
overarching infinity saga style story that helps
connect everything building up to avengers 5 it's
like you're watching a tv show that's serialized
and each of the episodes cost 200 million dollars
so they delay black widow again it means they'd
have to delay the shang chi movie which is coming
this summer the eternals movie then spider-man 3
doctor strange 2 thor 4 love and thunder and so
on the dominoes keep following well into 2023
most of you who are still in school right now
if they kept delaying movies you would probably
be married with children by the time avengers 5
rolls around but back last year in 2020 when the
lockdowns first started happening after the first
few movie delays everyone just started asking why
don't you just put black widow on disney plus why
not put the movies on disney plus disney pretty
much has infinite money and they can just take
it on the chin a little bit for a couple movies
what do we have here there's also that extra
thirty dollars that they charge for some of their
disney premier movies like the mulan movie where
you get it on disney plus but you have to pay an
extra thirty dollars to get it early they're also
doing that again with another movie raya in the
last dragon in march so i'll talk about that in
a second too that's another quote-unquote hybrid
release movie that they're doing and apparently
the reason why marvel did not do that with the
black widow movie last year because originally
they were going to release it in november didn't
have anything to do with them being worried about
losing money because yeah they'd lose a little bit
of money according to the rumor it had more to do
with the specific clauses in scarlett johansson's
contract that prevented disney and marvel from
releasing it on disney plus like apparently
scarlett johansson's contract for the black widow
movie has some special terms in it about how
they're allowed to release the movie and how she
earns a ton more money from a theatrical release
from the box office earnings than from streaming
earnings so apparently disney and marvel were
legally obligated under the terms of her contract
to have to release the movie in theaters in some
way they couldn't just put it on disney plus even
if they wanted to what's changed recently though
why there's all this renewed talk about a hybrid
release for black widow then putting it on disney
plus and in theaters on the same day has more to
do with what happened with the wonder woman 1984
movie that was the first real big comic book movie
this past year to do the hybrid release this last
christmas releasing the movie on streaming on hbo
max the same day that they release it in theaters
where theaters are open around the world because
there are some places where theaters are open
so warner brothers is doing this hybrid release
strategy for all of its movies in 2021 the big
difference between what warner brothers is doing
and what disney is doing is that warner brothers
isn't charging the extra 30 dollars premier access
money that disney is charging for some of its
films but per this variety insights report disney
and marvel are starting to feel like delaying the
black widow movie straight up will just cause more
problems than it will solve so they're thinking
about a hybrid release strategy to fix everything
they get to release the movie with no more delays
meaning we get to see shang qi this summer and
eternals in november no more delays for marvel
movies because right now just based on the rate of
how fast the virus situation is resolving itself
most summer movies seem like they're going to be
fine like theaters will mostly be open by later
this summer and per this hybrid release strategy
because they'd be releasing black widow in some
theaters even if it's not a ton it would be enough
to keep scarlett johansson from suing disney
for the tens of millions of dollars she would
potentially lose out on also on the side they'll
probably pass her some extra change like here
please take a couple extra million dollars don't
sue us warner brothers kind of had to do that with
gal gadot and patty jenkins when they released
wonder woman 1984 on hbo max they gave him a bunch
of extra money up front because they weren't going
to be earning a lot of extra money on the back end
you probably saw patty jenkins making a huge stink
about all this christopher nolan got really pissed
off about this too when they announced their big
2021 movies plan in fun fact 2 all the newer
marvel phase 5 movies that they've announced
like the fantastic four reboot movie the deadpool
3 movies ryan reynolds marvel is apparently also
altering all their standard movie contracts with
everyone to allow for streaming releases if things
like this happen in the future so actors directors
producers can't sue them if a big problem comes up
or another big pandemic and they have to release
movies on streaming so if you're wondering why you
didn't see a lot of disney movies on disney plus
last year it's not so much about them losing money
it's more about lawsuits from people in studio
contracts the next big disney plus test that
they're running is for the raya in the last dragon
movie is basically disney's version of avatar the
last airbender they just released a new trailer
for that this morning as i'm posting this video
that's going to be released the first week in
march so we won't have to wait too long to see
what happens with that but they're charging the
extra 30 dollars for the disney premier access
just like they did with the mulan movie so if
they're doing that for a pixar movie then you
can bet that they're going to charge an extra
30 for the black widow movie this may if they
also go with the hybrid release strategy like
variety is saying they will what will probably
happen you'll see in the next couple of months
is marvel will wait till the last possible second
that they have to before committing to an actual
release strategy like they'll just wait till
april to see if things get better and they don't
have to worry about it and they can just release
it normally in theaters like they originally
wanted to right now everyone's assuming that
things will mostly be back to normal by the summer
so may is just sort of that in-between period like
kevin feige himself is hopeful that things will
be fine but he also said that he's trying not to
make too many assumptions before we actually get
to may so let me know in the comments if you think
that marvel is going to pull the rip cord and do
a hybrid release strategy for black widow in may
or if you think the theaters will be fine by then
i'll be posting my Wandavision episode 4 video
this friday so make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss that there's a
bunch of big stuff coming up we'll start seeing
some more falcon and winter soldier footage really
soon too in some more loki footage everyone click
here for my brand new godzilla vs kong trailer
video and click here for my full Wandavision
episode 3 video in all my episode videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!